[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo quise venir a ustedes porque así
también los maestros y alumnos puedan
entender cómo nos sentimos nosotros los
niños a la escuela vamos a aprender pero
no sólo aprendemos estamos sentados en
un salón de clases escuchando al maestro
yo no me puedo consultar se ven cuántas
veces he escuchado lucas concéntrate
lucas con atención lucas ya siéntate
según la doctora yo tengo tdh que en mi
idioma es no me puedo concentrar
en finlandia ya han cambiado su forma de
vida en vez de tener sillas tienen pus
tienen sillones
[Música]
aquí se puede ver cómo tienen un salón
de clases pero también con sillas pero
se ve que es así están mucho más cómodas
que las que nosotros tenemos en la
escuela
ahí se puede ver cómo hay unos niños
sentados en unas pelotas porque yo a mí
me gusta mucho moverme me muevo me poco
centrar muy bien en matemáticas yo
matemáticas no me puedo concentrar yo
ahorita tengo el tema flexión y un fan
nos están pidiendo que miramos una
cancha de fútbol si tenemos una cancha
fuera porque no la podemos medir
aquí se puede ver cómo está en afuera
del 1 al 100 y pueden ir saltando para
ir aprendiendo de las tablas
aquí hay escaleras con las tablas y es y
hay unos bloques de lego a mí también me
gusta mucho el lago y luego este luego
se usa para las quebradas o algo hiciera
aquí se puede ver como mate mate se
puede ver como ellos si pueden medir si
no están viendo que veamos
una silla tenemos sillas hay que
medirlas
aquí se puede ver un vídeo como un niño
está en un pasillo sacando toda la
energía que tiene para poder
concentrarse en la escuela
yo aquí traigo pus porque si yo pudiera
estar sentado aquí me concentraría más
si yo tuviera ese pasillo con líneas
puede saltar sería más divertido
not all classroom of four walls qué
significa esto no todas no todas las
aulas tienen cuatro paredes
arte yo llevaba una semana con un
proyecto de arte y yo me quise salir de
mi dibuja la exploten
y no me habían dicho no sé por qué lo
hice pero dibuje un pato no sé por qué
pero ese pato al verlo me ayudó en
matemáticas y no sé por qué
pero fue muy raro
llevamos otra vez aquí a escaleras
ahí puedes si no te sabes las tablas
como yo puedes ir saltando ir
aprendiendo te las tablas para saber más
yo no me voy a sostener tengo dos
hermanos uno es más grande que yo ya va
en la secundaria el otro es más chiquito
yo si pudiera cambiar mi escuela hiciera
que mi hermano sé que no tiene como yo
de déficit de atención pero quisiera que
él también se pueda divertir más en la
escuela como yo
aprender pero aprendiendo de distintas
maneras gracias
[Aplausos]